okay i love this one a guy walks into a
bar
has a seat
what are you doing van says what are you
doing bartender says i have no idea is
this a joke man says is this a joke
bartender says no this is no joke
okay uh can i have a beer then please if
the guy says okay then can i have a beer
then please and the bartender says i'm
trapped
i'm a trapped man
what man says what bartender says i
don't know how to get out of this can
you help me
i'm stuck
in this
just stop and the guy says just stop
just stop that's what he says to help
and the bartender says i can't just stop
because we're just two insignificant
specks of dust in this huge galaxy and
on a tiny marble that god decided to
populate for some reason and i'm looking
for the punchline bartender says will
you help me find a punchline and the man
says no
no
that is rich
bring home the troops that's a good one
one for the books one for the knock
knock books yeah for the non-knock knock
section
you're not laughing
you must not get it maybe it was my
delivery can i
guy walks into a bar he sits down and
says what are you doing bartenders
i heard no idea you don't have to tell
it again i heard you it's not funny
it's just oh thank you for the ruling on
whether or not a joke was funny or not i
guess that's official it's called
guinness
uh can i just have a beer can i have a
beer the man says barkeep leans in real
close looks at the man in the eye says
no fella
are you still telling the joke
no irish
unless
you want to go out and come back with a
priest and a rabbi because i love that
one
all my wooden shoes
it's dutch
it's dutch to wear the wooden shoes the
pete home show premieres october 28th
after conan only on tbs
meet pete at petehomes.com